die welt schläft nicht haben sie frau
bundeskanzlerin auf dem cdu parteitag
gesagt aber wer nicht schläft ist nicht
zwingend wach betrachtet man die
politische lage abseits der deutschen
wie die öffentlichkeit wird eines klar
unter dieser großen koalition verschlag
wandelt deutschland seine zukunft
während andere nationen hellwache
politik betreiben
während die welt nicht in syrien die
karten neu mischen und klammern sie sich
an moralische appelle die in
kriegszeiten noch nie funktioniert haben
während das christentum im nahen osten
ausgelöst haben sie den verfolgern
massenweise schutz geboten
während die welt die wertlosigkeit des
iran deals erkannt hat haben sie bis zum
letzten moment daran festgehalten und
unseren israelischen verbündeten
kopierte und in der uno heult der
außenminister mit einer israelischen und
anti amerikanischen würfen in der
europäische union überlassen wir das
feld dem französischen präsidenten makro
nicht frau von der leyen sondern frau
lagarde ist die eigentliche chef in der
europäischen union
die finanz- und wirtschaftspolitik des
kontinents und in den kommenden jahren
eine französische und damit keine
sparsame sein schlaf
überlassen sie ihr die deutschen
sparschwein das nämlich zeichnet den
stoff bande aus er kann begrenzte
absichten fast und handeln was ihm fehlt
ist ein gefühl für die folgen
nirgendwo erfüllen sie diese diagnose so
entschieden wie in ihrer sogenannten
klimapolitik sie betrügen die bürger und
nutzen den allgegenwärtigen klimawandel
ganz ohne not für steuererhöhungen und
die abschaffung wirtschaftlicher und
bürgerlicher freiheiten wenn wir
erwarten in einigen jahren die
katastrophenszenarien ausgeblieben sind
werden die wirtschaftlichen schäden
dennoch irreversibel und deutschland im
weltweiten vergleich weiter abgestiegen
sein
sie wollen das elektro auto verzichten
auf die speicher und die erforderliche
grundlast sie wollen eine seriöse
energie und umwelt vor
sie betreiben laufen aber den demagogen
auf der straße hinterher
sie wollen weltmarktführer saubere
energien seien besitzen aber keine
schüssel ressourcen ob lithium kobalt
oder seltenen erden die
energiepolitische unabhängigkeit von
kohle und kernkraft tauschen sie lieber
gegen die abhängigkeit von china und
drittweltländer 1
das ende des bolivianischen big deals
ist die bankrotterklärung ihrer klaren
deutschen zukunftsstrategie anstatt das
solchen debakels zu lernen hintertreiben
sie und entwicklung alternativer
technologien wie zb den erneuerbaren
irgendwo diese die verwerfung in ihrer
welt rettungspolitik richtet sich dabei
gegen die schwachen die armen und die
familien ihre revolution gegen den
individualverkehr trifft zudem
alleinerziehende frauen und vätern
elektroautos in der luxus der reichen
mittelständler und handwerker leiden
darunter ebenso wie die bauern die
gestern vor dem brandenburger tor
rebellierten
sie machen eine politik für die wenigen
zehntausend gegen die mehrheit im land
und opfern die vernunft auf dem altar
die ideologie wie die politik ohne
folgenabschätzung aussieht haben sie am
freitag gezeigt es sehr wichtig so
sagten sie nicht die falsche menschen
einzuladen
dabei spielten sie mit der irgendwelche
umsiedlung hunderttausender
geringqualifizierter aus dem mittleren
osten und afrika
unser land und den kontinent christliche
konvertiten dagegen werden von behörden
abgeschoben und werden als glaubens
abtrünnige in ihrer heimat verfolgt das
ist keine gerechtigkeit frau merkel dass
es keine strategie
das ist das blanke recht des stärkeren
dem diese große koalition den weg
geebnet hat trotzdem predigen sie weiter
eine offene gesellschaft ohne zu
erklären dass ihre vermeintliche
toleranz und offenheit ein freiwillig
für euch asche lebensweisen für
unterdrückung von frauen und die
zerstörung der europäischen kultur sind
polizisten richter und staatsanwälte
kapitulieren längst vor kriminellen
überführen clanstrukturen vor
gewalttätern vergewaltiger vor schlägern
ein treffer die jüngst in leipzig eine
wehrlose frau dafür verprügeln dass ihre
firma wohnungen bauen will
in dresden hatte der wachschutz des
grünen gewölbes noch nicht einmal
dienstwaffe mit den mitteln unseres
rechtsstaates kommen wir gegen die offen
zur schau gestellte verachtung für unser
westliches denken und leben schon längst
nicht mehr an
ich appelliere an die frau
bundeskanzlerin hören sie auf zu
schlafwandeln wenn sie keine positive
visionen für unser land und für europa
haben
dann überlassen sie endlich anderen das
politische ruder so können sie ihre
verantwortung für deutschland am besten
wahrnehmen